MALE SPEAKER: Well, everybody,
welcome.
Thanks for coming to today's
Authors at Google Talk.
We are absolutely delighted to
have Dr. Peter Henry, the dean
of the Stern Business School,
here with us today.
He's here, first of all, to
talk about his new book,
"Turnaround--
Third World Lessons for First
World Growth," which talks
about in pretty interesting
detail what the First World
can actually learn from what
the Third World has been
living through for the last
number of decades.
And he has some pretty
interesting takes on it that
he'll share with all of us.
Before he does, though, I'd
like to embarrass him a
little, and give a little
about his background.
I had a choice of sort of a
one-line bio which said, he's
the dean of the Stern Business
School, or the
more extensive one.
And I'll go a little
bit longer.
He's not only the dean of New
York University's Stern School
of Business, but in 2008, he
also led President Obama's
presidential transition team in
its review of international
lending agencies, such as the
IMF and the World Bank.
He's a member of a number of
prominent boards, including
the National Bureau of Economic
Research, the Council
on Foreign Relations, and
the Kraft Foods Group.
He received his Ph.D. In
economics initially from MIT,
and that was preceded by a
bachelor's degree from Oxford
University, where he was
also Rhodes Scholar.
And his studies at the
University of North Carolina
where he was a Morehead Scholar
and a finalist in the
1991 campus-wide slam dunk
competition, which I think is
probably the most retweeted part
of his "New York Times"
interview that he did
a few years ago.
He was born in Jamaica
but lives in New
York with his family.
And we are absolutely delighted
to have him here.
So, Peter, we'd love
to hear from you.
Thank you.
PETER BLAIR HENRY:
Really, really
thrilled to be with you.
So we're at a really
important time.
And that sounds trite to say,
but there's a reason for it.
The world economy is in an
unprecedented period.
And I just want to start off
by giving you a few numbers
that capture the essence of
why I think the ideas in
"Turnaround" are so critical
to all of us.
So from 2002 to 2007, the world
economy experienced its
most rapid period of growth
in recorded history.
So since the time in which we've
had GDP growth numbers,
macroeconomic statistics
essentially, which is really
roughly over a century, we've
never had a period during
which the world economy
has grown as fast.
From 2000 to 2007, the world
economy grew at 4.9% per year.
But just to put that in
perspective, it's important
understand that emerging
economies, what are now called
emerging economies, really
drove that growth.
So emerging economies grew at
something close to 7% per
year, whereas advanced economies
grew at just under
3% per year.
So emerging economies are
driving global growth, and
emerging economies have turned
themselves around from what
were formerly known as Third
World countries to now become
emerging economies.
And what's really critical is
that, given where we are right
now, so 2002 to 2007
was a great period
of the world economy.
We're in a much less
robust period.
In 2012, the advanced nations
of the world grew at
only 1.3% per year.
Europe actually contracted.
Europe's in recession.
Emerging economies still
grew at 5.3%.
So in the aftermath of financial
crisis from 2008 to
2009, from which we're
still recovering--
and very importantly we know
from work by a number of
scholars, including Carmen
Reinhart and Ken Rogoff that
countries recovering from
financial crisis, when
financial crises are the cause
of the recession, countries
grow much more slowly when they
recover from those kinds
of recessions.
And that means we need emerging
economies to continue
to grow at rapid rates in
order to pull along the
advanced world as
it struggles.
And in particular, advanced
nations now look a lot like
Third World nations did three
and a half decades ago--
high debt, slow growth, and
a lack of direction.
And the central idea in
"Turnaround" is that the
history of the formerly Third
World, its history with the
struggle of economic reforms,
teaches us three really
important things that we need
in order for the advanced
nations to get back on track.
And so I want to share with you
very quickly what those
three things are.
And then I want to explore them
in a little more detail.
So what are the three key
lessons that we can learn from
emerging economies?
The Third World turned itself
around through discipline, and
discipline doesn't mean
fiscal austerity.
I'll define it in a second.
Clarity--
and the example of clarity I
want to use comes from the
small, tiny island of Barbados,
an even smaller
country than where I
come from, Jamaica.
And trust is also critical
to turnaround.
And I'm going to argue that the
emerging nations of the
world that are so critical to
driving global growth suffer
from what I call a trust deficit
with the First World.
And the trust deficit, the
lack of reciprocity and
respect of the Third World by
advanced nations, threatens
the willingness and ability
of Third World leaders to
continue on the path of
discipline and clarity that
has produced these record rates
of growth that are so
critical to our shared
prosperity.
So that's the book
in a nutshell.
I think it's important--
any time you talk about
macroeconomics, it's easy to
get lost in sort of GDP growth
rates, rates of inflation.
Economics ultimately matters
because we're
talking about people.
The reason why it's so critical
that the advanced
nations only grew at 1.3% last
year is because there's
unemployment.
1.3% is below what economists
call the trend rate of growth.
In advanced nations,
it's about 2.2%.
In the United States, it's
a little higher.
It's about 2.7218%.
So when countries grow below
their trend rate of growth,
unemployment tends to rise
through something called
Okun's Law.
And so that means if we're
growing below potential--
we're not living up
to our potential--
it's really hard
to create jobs.
And jobs are important,
not only for
incomes but for dignity.
So what I'd like to do before
going further is just to share
with you a short passage
from "Turnaround."
I'd like to read a short passage
from "Turnaround" that
I think provides some context
for understanding
why economic growth.
Why does economic growth
even matter?
Why are we talking about this
in the first place?
So with your permission, I'll
do a short reading.
This is from the first
chapter of the book.
"Growing up as a little boy on
the island of Jamaica in the
early 1970s, I cherished the
time I spent on the porch of
my grandmother's simple two
bedroom ranch house in
Kingston, the nation's
capital.
There, at 3 Windy Way in Harbour
View, a middle and
working class neighborhood at
the southern edge of the city,
I would sit on the brown
speckled tile, leafing through
the pages of Encyclopedia
Britannica, reading Bible
stories, and pouring over
back issues of "National
Geographic" for hours on end.
As sea breezes stirred the
needles of the casuarina trees
that lined the front yard and
shaded my world from both the
sun and the gazes of people
passing by on the sidewalk,
scents from Grandma's
kitchen--
pumpkin soup, baking bread,
brown sugar, and lime juice--
wafted through the air.
Things only got better as
the day progressed.
And the sun made its arc through
the cobalt expanse of
the Jamaican afternoon sky.
The approach of evening
was always my
favorite stretch of time--
a welcome pause between
the heat of day
and the fall darkness.
Grandma, finished with her
cooking and housework, would
come outside and sit with me
in the early evening air.
Encouraging children to read and
dream was what Grandma, a
former school teacher,
did best.
And she never missed an
opportunity to work with one
of her favorite students.
Sitting together in the fading
light, we lost ourselves in
conversation, accompanied
by the pulse of chirping
crickets, the reverberating
reggae beats from a nearby rum
shop, and the animated voices of
young men playing soccer in
the street.
These are the sounds of the
Caribbean, the lyrical
backdrop to Grandma's outdoor
classroom, where I asked
question after question about
the people and places I had
encountered in the
day's reading.
And my ever patient teacher
shared with me facts and
figures about distant lands.
Yet the greatest lesson I
learned from my grandmother
came not from something she read
to me, but from something
she did for someone else.
In Jamaica, as in many
developing countries, poverty
is never far away.
On one occasion, the ambient
sounds of those Caribbean
evenings gave way to the
piercing call of a woman at
the front gate.
'Mrs. Henry, Mrs. Henry.
You deh so?
Me beg you let me come in.'
When poverty calls to you
from the gate, you
have to make a choice.
You could avert your eyes,
perhaps even turn your back
and harden your resolve
not to engage.
But poverty will still be there
looking at you, even if
you don't have the courage
to return its gaze.
'Soon, come,' grandma called
out, as she lifted her tiny
slightly hunched frame from the
chair next to me, walked
across the tiles, stepped from
porch to cardboard, and made
the 30-foot journey
to the gate.
'Good evening, Ms. Mama, how
are you?' Ms. Mama's
appearance belied her reply.
'Me all right so far,
Mrs. Henry.'
Ms. Mama looked anything but all
right to me, as I watched
her follow grandma
toward the porch.
The closer Ms. Mama came to my
sacred classroom, the sharper
the contrast I discerned
between her
and my beloved tutor.
With bare feet, tattered
clothes, matted hair, and a
protruding belly, seemingly at
odds with her thin frame, Ms.
Mama appeared to be from an
entirely different planet than
my grandmother, who, with her
pressed and starched cotton
dress and neatly groomed
appearance, was the
quintessential school teacher
and matron of
the Anglican Church.
After inviting Ms. Mama to sit
down next to her and across
from me, grandma asked Ms.
Mama if she was hungry.
Ms. Mama replied, 'Yes,
Mrs. Henry.
It's a long time me not
eat, you know, ma'am.'
My grandmother disappeared
inside, then emerged a few
minutes later with a large
tumbler of milk and a plate of
warm hard dough bread,
dripping with butter.
I sat there, watching Ms. Mama
eat and listening to the
exchange, my grandmother
asking questions in the
Queen's English, Ms. Mama
responding in patois.
They continued on for some time,
Ms. Mama chronicling her
tough circumstances, my
grandmother offering words of
comfort and encouragement, until
the crumbs disappeared
from the plate, the milk was
drained, and my grandmother
sent Ms. Mama on her way, with
the familiar Jamaican
benediction--
'Walk good.'
I don't know how Ms.
Mama got her name.
And I don't know where
she came from.
But I can picture her today
just as I saw her in that
first encounter in late 1977,
when I was eight years old.
Over the next several months,
Ms. Mama appeared at my
grandmother's front gate with
increasing frequency.
One day in 1978, following what
turned out that the last
time I saw Ms. Mama, I asked my
grandmother, 'Grandma, Ms.
Mama has a big belly.
So why is she always hungry?'
My grandmother applied that some
people have big bellies
not from eating too much,
but because they never
get enough to eat.
For me, economics is
all about Ms. Mama.
I was drawn to the subject
because I wanted to help
people in developing countries
like my native Jamaica help
themselves.
Feeding the hungry is
an act of kindness.
Providing the hungry with the
means to feed themselves is an
act of empowerment that confers
dignity as well as
nourishment.
My grandmother was too old and
lacked the technical training
to give people like Ms. Mama
that kind of enabling
assistance.
I wrote this book because
I have no such excuse.
Helping people to help
themselves begins with a
simple observation.
Never in the history of the
world has a country
sustainably reduced poverty
without significantly
increasing its population's
average
overall standard of living.
The gains from economic
expansion may not be evenly
distributed.
So growth alone is not a
sufficient condition for
development.
But it is absolutely
necessary.
Without growth, life becomes a
series of zero sum struggles,
directed at preserving one's
share of limited resources.
With growth, the pie expands,
and the politics of
distribution no longer involve
such stark trade offs.
Because economic expansion
provides the most reliable
means of enabling the poor
to lift themselves out of
poverty, the critical question
is, what kinds of economic
policies lay the foundation
for growth?
The economic policy decisions
implemented in the months and
years ahead will determine
whether people eat or starve,
live or die, and not just
in emerging economies.
The financial crisis of
2008-2009 drove record numbers
of people in the United States
into unemployment,
foreclosure, and poverty, to say
nothing of the devastating
impact of its aftershocks
on the economies
and people of Europe.
Whether in the First World or
the Third, there is no place
to hide from the power
of policy."
So that's why I think
economics matters.
That's why growth matters.
And that's why macroeconomics,
the big picture, if you will,
is critical to our shared
prosperity in the future.
So what I'd like to do briefly
now is to talk about these
three elements-- discipline,
clarity, and trust--
these lessons from the Third
World struggle with economic
reforms that have so much to
teach us here in the First
World and advanced nations
about how we create more
prosperity here and abroad.
So discipline--
this one does not mean
fiscal austerity.
In the book, I talk about what
discipline means in the
context of free trade, capital
flows between nations, and
other economic policies.
I won't go into detail on
all those here today.
We can certainly have questions
about that during
the question and
answer period.
But I want to focus
on fiscal policy.
What does discipline mean in the
context of fiscal policy?
Because there's so much
discussion about fiscal policy
right now in the newspapers,
whether it be in the United
States, Western Europe,
or Great Britain.
So discipline, I define
discipline to be not
austerity, not the willingness
to take extreme measures.
But discipline means a sustained
commitment to
long-term prosperity, a
sustained commitment to a
pragmatic growth strategy that
is vigilant, and flexible, and
values what's good for the
country as a whole over what's
good for any individual,
interest group, or person
running for political office.
That's what discipline means.
And in the context of fiscal
policy, discipline is actually
no more complicated than the
story of the ant and the
grasshopper in "Aesop's Fables."
I have four sons, so
bedtime stories are a good way
for me to get a grasp on how
to make things very simple.
You know the story of the
ant and the grasshopper.
During good times, during the
summer, the ant saves.
He has a surplus so that
when winter comes, it
runs down the surplus.
The grasshopper had a party and
didn't have anything to
eat during the winter.
First World grasshoppers and
Third World ants is what I'd
like you to keep in mind.
And I'll give you two very
specific examples.
Let's take the United
States and Chile.
In 2001, the United States,
we had a $236
billion fiscal surplus.
We decided to give that
surplus back in
the form of tax cuts.
We gave tax cuts back and ran
deficits during that period
from 2002 to 2007, I mentioned
earlier, when the world
economy was booming.
Basic economics teaches us
that we should have done
exactly the opposite.
You save when times are good,
just like the ant.
And we know the rest
of the story.
And the story generalizes beyond
the United States.
Advanced nations as a whole
between 2002 and 2007, were
running fiscal deficits
of about 3% of GDP.
So when the crisis hit, we
didn't have a cushion.
And debts are now
where they are.
Chile in contrast, during those
boom years in 2002 to
2007, copper, Chile's principal
export, the price of
copper soared, in large part
due to rising demand in the
emerging world, building of
cities, building of homes,
wiring of offices and
homes and cities.
As the price of copper was
booming, the Chilean treasury
filled up with revenue.
And the people of Chile in 2008
took to the streets and
burned the finance minister
Andres Velasco in effigy,
asking him--
well, asking's a polite way--
demanding that he return the
people's money, so to speak.
He said no.
This is money for a rainy day.
When the financial crisis hit,
Chile had a surplus.
They were able to institute a $4
billion tax cut package to
help cushion the blow of the
recession, the financial
crisis, and help the poor.
Third World ants, First
World grasshoppers--
so discipline in the context
of fiscal policy, again,
doesn't mean austerity.
It means running counter
cyclical fiscal policy, saving
for a rainy day.
Second point, clarity--
I mentioned that I want to tell
you a story from the tiny
island of Barbados.
So you may say, what can you
learn from a small island?
Well, I think there's a lot we
can learn from a small island.
In 1992, Barbados was on the
brink of financial ruin.
They were running out of foreign
exchange reserves.
And their currency, the
Barbadian dollar, was pegged
to the US dollar--
1.7 Barbadian dollars
for each US dollar.
It had been pegged since
the early 1970s.
The United States economy
was in recession.
We had a credit crunch.
Barbados, being heavily
dependent on exports, in
particular tourism,
was suffering.
The International Monetary Fund
went to Barbados and sat
down with the leadership and
said, we think that you need
to devalue your currency.
You need to change the parity
from, let's say, 1.7 Barbadian
dollars to 1 US dollar to,
let's just call it 2.
Let's make that number up.
Barbados said no.
We don't want to do that.
There's a reason why our
exchange rate is fixed.
We're a small island.
We import much of
what we consume.
And if we devalue our currency,
we're worried that
this is going to cause an
inflationary spiral.
As the cost of imports goes up,
people are going to demand
much higher wages, and this is
going to set off higher costs.
And we're going to get
into a spiral.
But the others said, but
speaking of costs, much like
Europe today outside of Germany,
wages have risen too
quickly so that production
costs, unit labor costs, have
made you uncompetitive.
How are you going to
be competitive?
So rather than just saying they
weren't going to devalue,
the leadership in Barbados said,
OK, we've got a serious
problem on our hands.
We've got to propose
an alternative.
So what they did is
they got together.
The unions, the owners of
corporations, and the
government all sat down.
And they could see that the way
around this problem was
that they needed to cut wages.
The problem, of course,
is no one likes to
have their wages cut.
Raise you hand if you like
to have your wages cut.
So what do they do?
Well, a 9% wage cut
was on the table.
The government decided they were
going to go ahead with
this, a public sector
wage cut.
The public sector unions took
a strong opposition to this.
And 30,000 people took to the
streets of Bridgetown, the
capital of Barbados
in protest.
And just to put it in context,
there are only 250,000 people
in Barbados.
So this is roughly an eighth
of the population.
This is like 40 million people
marching on Washington in
protest of cuts in government
federal wages.
So the wage cut had been
proposed by Prime Minister
Erskine Sandiford.
The leader of the trade unions,
Sir Leroy Trotman, had
been against the wage cuts.
But when he saw this protest,
to his credit,
he changed his position.
He said this is not good
for the country.
We can't have this.
They resumed the three-party
talks.
And I'll just come to the end
of story very quickly.
The leadership of corporations
opened the books to workers.
And said, hey, what we're going
to do is we're going to
have a negotiated agreement
that in the future, wage
increases will be tied
to productivity.
So therefore, we're going to
share the fruits of prosperity
in such a way that we can
keep wages in line with
productivity so that costs
don't get out of control.
The union supported this.
The government didn't devalue.
Wages were cut by 9%.
Within a year, the Barbadian
economy recovered.
For his troubles, Prime Minister
Erskine Sandiford and
his party were kicked out
of office for 14 years.
When asked, in retrospect,
would you do it again?
The former prime minister said,
the price I paid was a
small price to save Barbados.
That's clarity.
That's clarity of purpose and
understanding what discipline
meant in that context.
Barbados, yes, it's a small
country, but the problems in
Barbados are very similar to
the problems that Europe
outside of Germany
faces today.
Wages have risen too fast,
relative to productivity.
Countries aren't competitive.
And just to connect clarity to
discipline, discipline doesn't
mean austerity in a
European context.
It means more reform
and less austerity.
Last point before opening
up to questions--
trust.
I made the claim that the trust
deficit, the lack of
trust between emerging market
nations and advanced nations,
stands in the way of our
future prosperity.
What do I mean by that?
Generalize now from Chile and
Barbados to the larger
emerging market countries,
the so-called BRICs--
the Brazils, the Indias, the
South Africas of the world.
The BRIC nations account for
roughly 21% of global GDP.
Brazil, India, China, all these
countries in their own
way have practiced discipline.
And it's important to say in
their own way, because what
discipline means for specific
policies differs from country
to country.
That general definition
applies.
It's sustained commitment
to long-term prosperity.
It's pragmatic.
It's flexible.
And what pragmatic
means depends on
the cultural context.
It depends on the political
context.
It depends on the country's
natural resources.
There's a whole range of things
that will determine
what's the optimal strategy
for a country to grow.
But the common thread is
discipline, a sustained
commitment to long-term
prosperity.
Through discipline, these
countries have turned
themselves around, accounting
now for 21% of global GDP, are
driving global growth.
But yet, at the institutions
that determine the contours of
international economic policy,
the International Monetary
Fund and the World Bank, these
countries only account for
11.5% of the voting shares.
They're underrepresented,
relative to their weight in
the global economy.
In contrast, the countries of
the eurozone account for about
24% of global GDP, and have
32% of the votes.
So we have an antiquated
structure that reflects the
relative importance of these
economies in the immediate
aftermath of World War II.
The lack of recognition, the
lack of reciprocity, in
international economic relations
undermines the trust
of leaders in the emerging
world with leaders in the
advanced nations.
And very importantly, makes it
very difficult for leaders in
the developing world to continue
to sell to their
electorates the need for more
discipline policies.
Because by the way, there's a
lot of work left to be done.
It's not just the advanced
nations--
and certainly the advanced
nations need to learn the
Third World lessons for
First World growth--
but there's a lot of work
that remains to be
been in emerging nations.
And in order for that work to
happen, we're going to need
cooperation.
Leaders in the developing world,
in the emerging world,
are going to need to be able
to show their citizens that
the advanced nations of the
world are willing to do as
they say, not just as they do.
So discipline, clarity,
and trust.
Looking at the history of the
Third World's struggle with
economic reform teaches us
these three things--
discipline and clarity
which build trust.
In the absence of which,
we get a trust deficit.
These are the key lessons,
whether it's fiscal policy,
trade policy, policy with
respect to international
capital flows that are key for
greater shared prosperity in
the future.
So let me stop there and
take any questions.
AUDIENCE: Given the example
of the prime minister in
Barbados, are politicians
deincentivized to make
long-term choices or maybe
incapable, given
the election cycles?
And when it comes to public
sector unions dealing with
elected officials, are they
essentially negotiating with
themselves?
PETER BLAIR HENRY: I think
it's certainly true that
election cycles in many cases
work against officials making
long-term decisions.
And the principal motivation,
frankly, for writing the book
was the desire to raise
expectations on the part of
the electorate.
So I wanted to take these
examples and illustrate to a
general readership that
discipline is a two-way street
in many respects.
So if we don't hold our leaders
accountable to a
higher standard, then we
shouldn't expect them to
behave with long-term vision.
So, yes, many of the incentives
go against making
long-term decisions, but I think
it's incumbent on the
electorate to actually
hold their
leaders to a higher standard.
So the key point in
the context of
unions is the following.
This is not to denigrate
all of the positive
things that unions do.
But it's a question of benefits
for an inside group
versus an outside group.
So if I could just generalize
the question a little bit, in
the case of Barbados, had they
not given into the wage cut,
those who had jobs would have
maintained their higher wages,
but at the cost of greater
unemployment to a larger
number of people.
And so the question is how
do you bring about shared
sacrifice so that not
only over time--
and in the case Barbados, you
had higher wages over time by
tying wage increases
to productivity--
so how do you not only get
people to have higher wages,
but how do ensure
full employment?
And that's one of the critical
problems facing Europe right
now is that those who are part
of the inside group, those who
are employed, are quite happy
with wages that are out of
line with productivity.
But the youth, in particular,
new entrance in the labor
force, are locked out.
And so we've got to reconvene
the conversation.
We've got to have a set of
policies that make it, for
instance, in a European context,
easier to hire and
fire workers so that companies
will hire more workers.
So again, I think there
has to be give and
take on both sides.
AUDIENCE: I had a question about
when you talked about
the Barbados and how the
corporations opened up.
Can you elaborate on what were
the incentives for the
corporations to do that or how
the government kind of created
that incentive for them?
PETER BLAIR HENRY: Sure.
So in Barbados, in particular,
the hotel industry was a
critical industry,
given tourism.
And speaking of incentives, the
owners realized that when
you've got 30,000 people
marching in the streets, it's
not good for tourism.
And so in that case, there was
a realization that, OK, gosh,
we have to share in
this pain as well.
This can't just be a matter of
teachers, and firemen, and
policemen bearing the full
brunt of this adjustment.
We have to make some concessions
as well.
And the reason why I like to use
the Barbados example is it
shows that social cohesion,
social compact, social
compromise, is possible.
But again, it takes leadership
to point to people that it is
in their self-interest
to do these things.
AUDIENCE: So on your first
point, when you mentioned,
basically, the Keynesian
approach is the way to go,
given the current polarization
in the political systems
across the globe--
I mean, the US, but also
Italy, France, UK--
aren't politicians not
incentivized to actually do
this but make a short-time
decisions that will be better
in the end just for their
political future, instead of
making long-term goals
that might be
better for the country?
PETER BLAIR HENRY: Yeah, I think
it's certainly an issue.
And my hope in writing this book
is to get the discussion
away from polar extremes that
are really rooted in nothing
more than opinions and to just
bring facts to bear.
And so let me just stress some
facts that I actually think
really highlight why fiscal
austerity is not the right
approach, for instance.
It's not my view,
these are facts.
So what do I mean by that?
So one of the ways in which
I try to understand what
discipline actually means,
it's not my view of
what this one is.
It's a market view.
So I actually ask the question,
how does the stock
market, or how did the stock
market, in these emerging
countries, in these developing
countries, respond when
governments implement
big policy changes?
You mention, why would you
look to the stock market?
Why is the stock market a useful
measure of anything?
Well, the stock market doesn't
care about ideology.
Stock market's not Keynesian or
monetarist or anything else.
Will the policy that's enacted,
on average, create
economic growth in the
future and reduce
risk, or increase risk?
And so when the stock market
responds positively what it's
basically telling you is that
the implemented policy change
is likely to create a value.
And so in the context of fiscal
austerity, what we
learn is there are 81 episodes
over the course of three and a
half decades of developing
countries
implementing fiscal austerity.
56 of those episodes turned out
to be implemented during
what's called moderate
inflation,
inflation below 40%.
25 of those episodes are
during high inflation.
In the high-inflation episodes,
the stock market
responds extremely positively.
It goes up by about 60% in real
dollar terms over about a
year in anticipation of
these policy changes.
So austerity's a value-creating
proposition
when inflation is on the order
of 300% per year or more as it
was in the case of Brazil
or Mexico in the 1980s.
When inflation's below 40%,
the stock market falls by
about 30%, when governments
implement fiscal austerity.
So what that means for
politicians, to answer your
question directly in the current
European-US context,
is that implementing austerity
in a 2% or 3% inflation
environment is not a winning
proposition.
Do politicians have the
incentive to recognize that?
I think politicians
can at least agree
that growth is good.
So that's why I wanted to
get this message out.
AUDIENCE: Stock markets are back
to their pre-2008 levels.
That should be--
PETER BLAIR HENRY: Only if you
don't adjust for inflation.
So in real terms, we're
still below.
And it's a very good point,
because there are a lot of
reasons why stock markets
have gone up recently.
We've got expansionary
monetary policy.
Corporate profits are high.
And it brings me to the second
point, which is that the stock
market responding positively
to a policy change, again
going back to the passage that I
read, is a necessary but not
sufficient condition for
shared prosperity.
In other words, the stock market
responding positively
to a policy change is telling
you, yes, that policy change,
reducing inflation or austerity
in the midst of high
inflation does create value.
But that's just the
first step.
So in the present context, even
though stock markets are
rising, there's still a question
of well, what's next?
What do we have to do to, for
instance, in the United
States, restore trust between
business and government so
that firms start to
invest again?
Investment right now as a
fraction of GDP in the United
States is down around 15%.
About a decade ago it
was as high as 25%.
That means on average,
corporations, the private
sector's investing close to $1
trillion dollars a year less
per year than it was.
And that's one of the reasons
why we haven't seen a really
robust recovery, a pickup
in jobs and growth.
And so the stock market is a
very helpful place to start a
conversation and get
away from ideology.
Because you can ask the
question, is this policy
change likely to create
or destroy value?
But it's not the place to
end the conversation.
Because stability is a necessary
but not sufficient
condition for shared
prosperity.
AUDIENCE: Thanks again
for joining us.
My question is around the trust
deficit you mentioned.
And you gave an example between
First and Third World
country trust issues.
How about the trust deficit with
the US itself and how it
impacts our innovation
and growth?
I've seen some numbers where
US was behind even China in
terms of trust.
And so is there anything we
can learn from Third World
countries to restore trust?
PETER BLAIR HENRY: Yeah, that's
a great question.
So there's a passage in the book
that makes reference to a
West Indian aphorism that
my dad used to say a lot
when I was a kid.
And the aphorism is "Long
road draw sweat.
Shortcut draw blood." It's
almost self-explanatory.
The long road makes you sweat.
There's no easy way to get
to the right place.
And we've taken a lot of
shortcuts, whether it be the
financial markets, and all the
things that went wrong, over
extension of loans, people who
can afford loans, and all the
things that went wrong in the
run-up to the financial crisis
where effectively we undermined
trust in a number
of ways, between consumers,
lenders, investors,
shareholders of corporations.
So you can't rebuild
that overnight.
And I think it's very important
for us remember, as
in many things in life, it takes
a long time to build a
reputation.
It can be destroyed like that.
So the lesson is, from Third
World nations that have worked
so hard to get beyond where
they were in the 1970s and
1980s where there was
a lack of trust--
as reflected in low stock
prices, and lack of
investment, and low growth--
to building that trust, that we
need to take the long road.
And we need to do the basic
things that are necessary in
order rebuild trust.
So there's no easy answer.
We just have to do it.
We just have to do it,
everything from restoring
confidence in lending, to
giving clarity about the
future so that businesses will
begin to invest again.
And I think we just keep doing
it, get on the right track,
and stay on the right track.
It becomes self-reinforcing.
AUDIENCE: It seems like some of
the challenge that people
are coming up with in the
questions is this problem
between the short-term
incentives and
the long-term vision.
PETER BLAIR HENRY: Right.
AUDIENCE: But that also suggests
some amount of
democratization.
So I'm wondering where some of
your takeaways fit within the
academic tradition that a little
bit of authoritarianism
is good, what you're trying
to put out here.
PETER BLAIR HENRY: It's
a great question.
So it's certainly true that if
you look out in the world,
there are examples of countries
that have been able
to implement long-term policies,
discipline policies,
throughout their
authoritarianism.
But what makes me very hopeful
is that there are also more
than a few examples of
complicated democracies that
actually implement long-term
value creating policies.
I think Brazil's an
excellent example.
So Brazil in 1994, under the
leadership of Fernando
Henrique Cardoso implements the
Real Plan, which basically
cuts off inflation permanently
for the first time.
But what's really important is
that following Cardoso, Lula
da Silva was elected in 1998
and was elected on a policy
platform that many people
thought that Lula was going to
go back to the policies of old,
printing money to finance
the deficit, and would drive
inflation back up.
In fact, if you look at
financial markets in the run
up till Lula's election, risk
premium went up and really,
really reflected that.
But the genius of Lula was he
had broad inclusive language
but harnessed the market
to deliver those goals.
And Brazil is still a
low-inflation country today.
And it's provided that
stability, plus some--
more open markets,
market-friendly policy.
So there are examples, whether
it be Brazil in 1994, India,
actually under Rajiv Gandhi as
early as 1986 beginning to
move in a more market-friendly
direction.
And an even more recent example,
a very fledgling
democracy, Indonesia in 1997,
during the Asian financial
crisis, was one of the most
hard-hit countries, an
authoritarian country
that made a
transition to democracy.
It's still a fledgling
democracy.
There's a way to go.
But it's doing a good job
of managing its natural
resources, which is typically
a real problem.
And then there are the
democracies like Ghana and
West Africa.
So I'm hopeful.
I'm hopeful.
But again, I think your question
is an excellent one,
because I think it points to the
need for us in the First
World, who've gotten so
paralyzed and divided, to look
up and look out and say, gee,
there are all these countries
who, in fact, sometimes we were
teaching what to do in
order to grow.
They've learned the lessons.
Now maybe we need to sit down
and actually look at them more
closely and become students
again and figure out how we
get to yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi, yeah, so, just
on the topic of economic
growth, but then also versus
poverty or reducing poverty, I
guess sort of to the three
points that you spoke to
improving economic growth, would
you say that those are
also in line with the idea
of wealth distribution or
reducing poverty, or not
necessarily that the two go
hand in hand?
PETER BLAIR HENRY: So I would
say that growth is a necessary
but not sufficient condition
for poverty reduction.
So if you want to reduce
poverty, you need growth.
You need resources to deal
with the issues.
Now is growth alone
sufficient?
Probably not.
So let me give you a
specific example.
Or is stability alone, which
creates growth, sufficient?
So if you're a country that
reduces inflation, so let's
say you're a country
like Brazil.
Stock market goes up
because you stopped
the inflation problem.
But now the cost of capital's
gone down for corporations.
But if you don't have policies
that make it easy for
companies to hire workers, or
encourage companies to hire
workers, then you're not going
to see the kinds of employment
and wage gains that you would
see in an environment where
you did do that.
And so you need a combination
of policies.
And in that case as well, not
only policies to create more
employment, but then you
probably also do need policies
to directly address the issues
of poverty, as Brazil did in
addition to its inflation
stabilization policies.
But importantly, it's the growth
that gives you the
resources that you need to deal
with whatever range of
societal problems it is you want
to deal with, whether it
be poverty or something else.
One of the stories I tell in
chapter two of the book is a
story of my own native Jamaica
in which a very charismatic
leader, Michael Manley--
so in some sense very similar
to Lula da Silva in terms of
just sort of raw charisma--
brilliant man who was
unconstrained by external
reality, an oil shock that hit
in the early 1970s, had a set
of goals, including poverty
reduction, by being
unconstrained by what was
happening with oil prices and
economic reality, really drove
the country into a terrible
economic place, almost 13
straight years of economic
contraction, which drove
poverty way up.
So in many ways, the first rule
of poverty reduction and
growth is to provide
stability.
Because without stability,
there's really nothing else.
But stability is a place to
start, not a place to stop.
MALE SPEAKER: So if I could just
ask one last question as
we kind of wrap up.
A lot of what you've talked
about is a compelling thesis.
It sort of makes sense.
It hangs together.
It seems premised on cases where
things got really bad
before the leading figures sort
of said, OK, I need to be
disciplined.
I need to be committed.
I need to establish trust.
In the developing world, these
lessons seem applicable.
Are things bad enough that
people will listen?
Or do they need to get worse?
PETER BLAIR HENRY:
I sure hope so.
It's true.
The good news and in some
way the bad news in
the advanced nations--
and I think Japan is a great
example-- so Japan has had a
really, by any measure, a
tremendous under performance
over the last two decades.
And they've got a new central
bank governor who's going to
try new approaches to get rid
of deflation and get the
country going again.
But what makes it so difficult
for advanced nations like
Japan and the United States to
actually tackle their problems
is the overall level
is still very high.
And so we become complacent.
We become used to gridlock
or under performance.
And so I hope things have
gotten bad enough.
And I hope that, frankly, we can
be motivated just by the
things which, frankly in this
country, have always been sort
of core values, which is our
commitment to excellence.
We shouldn't be satisfied with
2.2% growth last year and 1.3%
growth in the advanced
nations.
Those are low expectations.
So I'm hopeful that people
will re-turn around and
recognize that there are a lot
of lessons out there that are
there for the taking.
And that if we just rededicate
ourselves to excellence,
there's a much more prosperous
future for all of us.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you very
much for taking the time and
sharing your insights with us.